[Music]
all season long we're celebrating
hometowns all across the country like
the dallas fort worth area in texas
where real life cowgirl and former miss
rodeo america pam minnick shares her
hometown spirit take it away pam
howdy drew i'm pam minnick here at ktvt
cbs 11 in fort worth dallas texas along
with chief meteorologist scott padgett
and what we love about this area of
north texas is the perfect blend of
cowboys cowgirls culture and
entertainment now we're headed to see
the dallas cowboys because cbs 11 is
your official cowboy station
we're at the home of the cowboys dallas
cowboys football team that is and my
favorite part of the team are the dallas
cowboy cheerleaders who have a message
for you drew welcome to a t stadium
[Music]
how about those moves drew you know even
when it's not football season you've got
to see the cowboys stadium the size the
scope of it the artwork the memorabilia
it's worth seeing
[Music]
is the national cowgirl museum and hall
of fame in fort worth texas where women
who shape the west with their can-do
spirit are recognized and i'm proud to
be one of those honorees dr diana vela
what makes the cowgirl museum a must see
we are the only institution in the
nation that honors those women who are
shaping the west and changing the world
where else can you see miranda lambert's
guitar a game of thrones saddle and
annie oakley shotgun in one place
the historic fort worth stockyards is
really where i feel most at home what
really makes it unique is the fort worth
herd daily longhorn cattle drive every
day at 11 30 and four o'clock this herd
of majestic longhorns parades down the
streets of exchange avenue it's a sight
to see and there's more there's shopping
dining a rodeo and even a two-step to
billy bob's texas the world's largest
honky-tonk where george strait garth
brooks even ringo starring kid rock have
performed
well drew that's just a little taste of
what makes fort worth dallas so special
i hope you love it as much as i do and i
can't wait for you to visit you know
they say that everything is bigger in
texas so i can't wait to show you more
see you soon
thanks for sharing your hometown with us
pam next time i'm there i'll look you up
and we can do some two-stepping or maybe
hit the eamon carter or the kimball have
some guac and chips at joe t garcia's
what do you say
tell us what makes your hometown special
on our website at thedrewberrymoore
show.com so we can celebrate you too
[Music]
you